you went on Snoop Dogg has a talk show
god bless him yeah favorite people Snoop
Dogg has a talk show and you went on his
talk show and it's unlike any other talk
show I've seen because he is not afraid
to enjoy himself during the program
he hasn't been afraid to enjoy himself
for the last 20 we've had we've actually
had he's been on this show many many
many times and we actually couldn't let
him stay in his his greenroom his
dressing room anymore because he and his
entourage will be smoking so much that
they would drift through the
air-conditioning system and it would
come out and get our audience they would
get a contact high I'd come out they'd
be laughing at the setup and not the
punchline they were just giggling all
over the place it was insane so we
finally started to get him his own place
just so that the audience wasn't high
sorry gang
we have a clip of you Oh get over it you
know gonna smoke that stuff I tell ya
you've got to take the SATs tomorrow we
have a clip of you on I love this clip
of you on Snoop Dogg's show let's take a
look if I could work with anybody dead
or alive I'd want to work with
maybe Gandhi okay
Gandhi was destroyed yeah no [ __ ]
Gandhi's the [ __ ] that's the greatest
thing ever said about Gandhi let's take
a break more with Kathy Bates in just
seconds stick around
you